alors si tu as déjà vécu des expériences
paranormales apa vous peut-être sûrement
isabelle mais moi je n'ose pas le dire
parce que ça va faire la peine à ma
soeur mais ma soeur elle semblait trucs
et un jour on était dans trente secondes
à son nom mais alors ils prennent tout
nous dire elles sont comment elle il ya
des trucs mamans qui viennent et qu'elle
semble qu'elle sent venir
bien sûr à des texans les biens-fonds
isabelle elle était avec son mari en
voiture et un risque banon mais parler
d'eux
elle était avec son mari en voiture et
nous avec et sur l'autoroute bas quelque
chose me dit qu'il fallait qu'elle
s'arrête et qu'on descende donc
évidemment nous a dit faucon descente de
voiture
son mari alik sommes tous les hommes
mais pourquoi il cite moi pourquoi le 10
décembre
on mérite des cendres du jeu on descend
et le moteur a explosé juste après qu'on
soit on est sorti de la voiture et ma
soeur sans souvent des choses comme ça
bah oui et tu racontes n empêche pas
d'être une remarquable l'infirmière des
partis sur un mode délire complètement
sur le truc elle sort des trucs
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]